do you have advice for young people i
think high school students
maybe uh
undergrads college students
about career
life how to live a life they can be
proud of
you've had one heck of a life
some of them are really cheesy but
they're true
live a life you can be proud of
number one
if you wake up every morning and you
hate what you do change
the [ __ ] station
do not live and stay in that perpetual
cycle of [ __ ]
it's not worth it it's not
it's not what you're on this planet for
you're worth more than that then the
monotony of waking up going to work
hating your life drinking yourself to
sleep and functioning
do yourself a favor the thing i scream
about on the show so much is move your
[ __ ] body move your body
get your blood moving allow your body to
to do what it's here for go for a run go
for a walk if you can't run walk to the
fridge three times more than maybe you
did before but you're moving
pay attention to the [ __ ] you look at
more now than ever we are seeing uh our
younger generation just be force-fed
information from one side or the other
and none of it makes sense none of it's
understandable it just causes chaos in
the brain
really pay attention to what you you
listen to
something i've had to learn to do is
make time for myself
all of this
working 18 hours a day not sleeping just
work work work that doesn't work that's
not sustainable it's not healthy and
it's not it's not anything anyone should
be doing
balance is important
but if you're going to take the time
to do something for yourself
don't make it sitting in front of the tv
for six hours eating a bag of chips
drinking a coke
make it i'm gonna go for a walk maybe
listen to a podcast where i can learn
something
make it
i'm gonna go volunteer somewhere nobody
does that anymore but make it i can go
volunteer somewhere honor house
they have no paid employees they have
one everybody is a volunteer they're
[ __ ] phenomenal
just
do whatever you're gonna do do it with
some [ __ ] drive put some goddamn
effort into your life
and pick something in a career that's
gonna make you happy
not something that's just gonna give you
six figures because that's not gonna
make you happy i can tell you right now
i have everything in the world and the
last thing i want is more things i want
less i want the woods and i want quiet
because that's what's important to me
i want my family to matter the people
around me to matter and the small group
i keep that tight knit i have
i want them to wake up every minute
knowing that they have a friend that
they can call on the other line that
isn't just like how's it going that can
actually have a conversation a
meaningful intelligent
caring conversation
we are just breeding these kids to be
followers who digest [ __ ] who
reverberate things they don't fully
understand and have opinions on stuff
they have no business talking about
yeah
with an open mind humbly think deeply
about the world
you